In this video, I will walk you through
an implementation of token-based
authentication in Flask.
There are several ways of implementing
this functionality in your code, but
this is one solution I have to be found
rather easy to understand and secure.
I have a new models.pi file that
contains the user model and
the basic HTTP authorization
code from the previous exercise.
Here I have a secret key, which is just
a random string of 32 characters that I
will use to sign my tokens.
I will also make a new method
here called generate_auth_token.
I will make the token be an encrypted
version of a dictionary that hides
the ID of the user.
The token will also have
an expiration time embedded in it.
Which by default,
will be of TEN mins or 600 seconds.
The verification is implemented in
a verfy_auth_token static method.
A static method is used because
the user will only be known
once the token is decoded.
Now in my views.pi file,
I'll make a new end point that
the client can use to request a token.
Note that this inpoint is protected
with the auth.loginrequired decorator
from Flask HTTPI, which requires that
the user name and password are provided.
Next I'll add code for handling
a token when my server receives one.
The HTTP basic authentication protocol
does not specifically require that user
names and passwords are used for
authentication.
These two fields in the HTTP
header can be used to transport
any type of authentication information.
For token based authentication, the
token can be sent as a user name, and
the password field can be ignored.
This means that now the server can
authenticate requests with the user name
and password.
And request with just a token.
The verified password callback needs
to support both authentication styles.
This new version of the verified
password callback attempts
authentication twice, it first tries to
use the user name argument as a token.
If that doesn't work, then user name and
password are verified as before.
I will run my web server again and
send the following kernel request.
In order to get an authentication token,
I will run my web server again, and
send the following kernel request,
in order to get an authentication token.
Now the protected resource can be
obtained authenticating with the token.
Note that in this last request, the
password is written as the word blank.
The password in this request can
be anything, since it isn't used.
the code, end request,
can be found in the instructor notes.